at this altitude this episode is brought
to you by wordpress my go-to platform
for blogging writing online creating
websites everything I love WordPress to
bits my site every site just about that
I have is run on WordPress and the lead
developer of WordPress matt mullenweg
has appeared on this podcast many times
the very first episode in particular is
amazing the second I took a ton of notes
on so you should check it out but
WordPress where do I even begin I mean
the New Yorker uses it jay-z Beyonce
they use it 5:38 TechCrunch Ted CNN time
whether you are looking to create a
personal blog a business site both
neither something else you'll make a
huge impact when you build your website
on wordpress.com and directly from some
friends at Google I'm not going to quote
them by name but they say that WordPress
offers the best out-of-the-box SEO the
search engine optimization imaginable so
if you're on WordPress you immediately
have a leg up on everybody else on
search engines and so forth in my
experience I'm no medical doctor of
search engine optimization but I will
say that I used WordPress for years and
fell in love with it to the extent that
I became very close friends with Matt
and then became an investor slash
advisor to automatic which runs
WordPress com that is how much I believe
in this and that's how a lot of my most
successful products and investments have
come about because I'm in love with X
and then I seek out X nearly 30 percent
of the Internet is run on WordPress and
that includes everything from the huge
sites that I mentioned to neighborhood
sites and it is super easy
to get started there's no need to worry
about security or upgrades or hosting
they offer 24/7 support and handle all
of that which allows you to focus on
creating the highest quality content you
can with the least amount of friction I
don't have to worry about downtime I
don't have to worry about getting
emergency emails if I'm on vacation or
something like that and WordPress is my
go-to solution for all of this I trust
all of my most important texts on the
Internet to WordPress and they can't buy
that with a sponsorship they can't buy
that with anything I want uptime uptime
uptime and quality and that is what I
have selected after everything that I've
looked at so check it out go to
WordPress that's wor DPR ESS comm
wordpress.com forward slash Tim to
receive 15% off of your website today
that's wordpress.com forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
audible which I have used for many many
years I absolutely love audiobooks and
they are one of my favorite ways to pass
the time when I travel I'm on the road
all the time and audible allows me to
consume many more books than I possibly
could otherwise I have two audio books
to recommend right off the bat the first
is perhaps my favorite audio book of all
time and it's the only audio book I've
wanted to listen to twice in a row the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman it's
amazing and you will thank me there are
a few different versions
I like the version that Neil narrates
himself one of the most soothing voices
of all time the second book is
vagabonding by Rolf Potts pio TTS which
had a huge impact on my life and form
the basis for a lot of what would later
become the 4-hour workweek so go to
audible.com for word slash Tim and you
can choose one of these two books or any
of many many other options that could be
books magazines and much more as a
listener of the Tim Ferriss show you can
also access a free 30-day trial just go
to audible.com forward slash to him you
can't make more time but you can make
the most of it so turn your travel or
your commute into something more with a
free trial at odd
go to audible.com forward slash Tim to
start now and get your free 30-day trial
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show where it is my job to
deconstruct world-class performers to
tease out the habits routines favorite
books breakfasts whatever it might be
that you can test and apply in your own
life the specifics the details the
beliefs habits and so on that you can
actually use in the real world in this
episode we have a fantastic guest I've
wanted to connect with for a very long
time Darren Aronofsky so who is Darren
we're gonna get to that in a second but
he was introduced to me by another
podcast guest Peter
attea who is a medical doctor and
endurance athlete or he would say former
endurance athlete and I encourage you to
also check out his episodes because
it'll put a lot in context and Peter has
three episodes if you just go to tim
blog /a tia atti a you will find three
of them they start with dr. peter tia on
life extension drinking jet fuel ultra
endurance human foie gras and more to
the next one optimizing investing blood
hormones and life then my life extension
pilgrimage to Easter Island it's a long
story but check it out Tim da blog /i
Tia but back to Darren Darren Aronofsky
you can find him on twitter and
instagram at darren da rren Aronofsky AR
o n o FS KY to say hello and he's doing
some very cool stuff on instagram and
darren aronofsky comm is the founder and
head of the production company protozoa
pictures he is the acclaimed and
award-winning filmmaker behind cult
classics like pi requiem for a dream and
the wrestler which are really just the
tip of the iceberg when it comes to his
filmography but going back to the
beginning pi his first film that was
1998 won him early plaudits and a Best
Director award at the Sundance Film
Festival Aronofsky that's Darren later
directed and produced The Wrestler
which I absolutely loved and made its
world premiere at the Venice Film
Festival which happens to be the oldest
Film Festival in the world
where it became only the third u.s. film
in history when the esteemed Golden Lion
award Darrin later directed the Indy
box-office phenomenon Black Swan which
won Natalie Portman the Academy Award
for Best Actress and Garner's for other
Oscar nominations including Best Picture
then his biblically inspired epic Noah
opened at number one at the box office
and grossed more than 362 million
worldwide his latest movie is mother
with lowercase M and an exclamation
point a psychological horror thriller
film starring Jennifer Lawrence Javier
Bardem ed Harris and many others
Michelle Pfeiffer goes on I've had a
chance to t see this movie and I'm
stumbling over my words because it's
it's hard to describe it was
mind-bending super intense and I walked
around in a dream state for an entire
day after seeing this it is I unlike
anything you have ever seen so if you
want to strap on your seat belt and go
on a roller coaster
I suggest that you check it out so
without further ado please enjoy my
conversation with Darren Aronofsky
Darren sir welcome to the show thank you
Tim I have been looking forward to
meeting you for some time now thank you
I'm a big fan as well we have quite a
few mutual friends and I have some
suggestions I won't mention them by name
yet as to topics and questions but I
wanted to start with a question about
your writing environment oh that's a
good question
I've read a little bit about a desk okay
Huell your desk yeah could you describe
this desk and if you still use it it was
interesting I know you've spent time in
Japan and so I was in Japan probably
promoting I don't know if it was piyo
requiem for a dream and I went to some
spa town south of Tokyo I can't remember
the name of it and I guess it was the
kind of Nexus of this place where they
make these puzzle boxes I don't know if
you've ever seen them they're kind of
beautiful pattern wooden boxes and you
can't really see any hinges or any
spaces but if you slide a few
panels in a certain order and it could
be up to eight sixteen thirty-two moves
depending on how much money you want to
spend eventually it opens and there's a
secret compartment and it blew my mind I
had never seen any type of souvenir like
it I bought a couple and I played with
it for a long time and then I think it
was early days of internet so I started
to Google a little bit about what it is
there's a whole art form I won't try to
butcher the Japanese word for it but I
then noticed that there were contests
worldwide and that there was there was
this one dude who was winning year after
year contest and he was a guy in
Colorado so I was like oh that's kind of
interesting and so just randomly I
tracked them down and I sent him an
email
his name's Kagan sound and I sent him an
email I said hey you know did you ever
think of doing any furniture and he's
like well actually I'm working on this
thing for a library and I said well
it'll be interesting maybe to do a desk
out of it and he loved the idea and then
he it was amazing he said it's true
master maybe we should probably go home
for it house knock it out I would love
to say David saw it I don't know if he
told you about it but he freaked the
hell out David Blaine yeah this is right
this is part of why I'm asking okay yeah
so anyway he ended up this this master
so the whole thing has made it
completely out of wood he doesn't work
with any other materials but wood and
I'm not sure the count on puzzles in the
desk but it's I mean scores of them and
eventually they all sort of work
together to build to a final release
where you basically it he was able to
turn it into a musical instrument
he created bellows all controlled with
wood and the drawers and by actually
pushing the drawers that creates sounds
and it has a full octave and he asked me
what song I wanted and it has he then
was able to build it basically a
computer a thing that has switches that
are all blown by the bellows and if
they're done in the right order a panel
flaps open in the back with a secret
draw so it took him five years to do it
and it
insane and I think the price we agreed
on was a crime at the beginning cuz I'm
to him or depriving him it was a crying
to him and I felt so and then I realized
I didn't have a chair for it so then I
said you know we should make a puzzle
chair for it and I know that five years
later and I paid through the nose for
that to get them back but it's a
beautiful thing and it's a great desk
and I want to say I read this in a
previous interview that you've referred
yourself as a nomadic writer riding in
one place for a few weeks and then
moving locations yeah how does your
writing process differ project to
project or do you how do you you say the
desk that we were just talking about and
combine that with shifting locations I'm
on book deadline right now so I'm
thinking about this and of course I'll
do anything to avoid writing interesting
including interviews exactly I
understand that procrastination but you
know my writing partner a guy right with
a lot re handle once said to me probably
the most important thing I taught to him
taught him was that and I didn't do this
on purpose is that procrastination is
part of the process that actually your
brain needs a break every once in a
while and not to say to abuse that but
to be a little easy on yourself and
allow yourself to go to a book store to
go to a museum to just even if you were
serious about your work even when you're
not working or you are working your
brain is putting stuff together and you
know inspiration comes from the
strangest places as we all know you know
you suddenly stumble on something that's
exactly what you were looking for when
you didn't know you were looking for it
but it's changed my writing process I
used to what I do was a tremendous
amount of prep where we would do a
tremendous amount of research and
outlines
and eventually get to a place where we
we were exhausted with that and then I
would do something called the muscle
draft where I would go and disappear
somewhere usually far away where I could
be very alone and be very lonely and
that loneliness would inspire me to work
hard and fast and I would muscle out a
draft which meant I would never go back
it would it was all about just pounding
through it to get to the end as quick as
possible and it was like a two three day
process and you come that out with like
if it ended up being 120 page screenplay
you'd have an eight 79 80 page
screenplay
but in that muscle draft there would be
moments when you you know when you do
enter that zone I don't know if you have
a term for it if you run into it but
there's that zone when you kind of
forget time it's you know I imagine
athletes are doing in rock musicians
seem to be doing it when they their eyes
roll back in their head but as a writer
everyone's well you get that we're where
time disappears and something comes out
on the page and that scene is often
something that ends up staying all the
way through to the end of the process
when you are muscling out that first
draft is it in are you using
screenwriting software is it just kind
of brain vomiting bullets on into a word
document what is it look it's I'm trying
to think I mean you know final draft has
been around for a long time now and it's
a great software that I've used I don't
I don't know if Pi was written on it
it's hard to that was 97 so I can't I I
doubt it probably I probably was
formatting stuff back then I don't
really remember but you know that that
just helps you it helps you work quicker
because you know instead of dealing with
indentation you press tabs and shortcuts
to get through it quicker I mean you
know screenwriting is very much like
sculpture in the sense that you know if
you start with a piece of clay you don't
want to just focus on the hand you know
any artist that does that will tell you
you know then the hand will be like
grossly look detailed and enlarged
compared to the rest of the body you
kind of just want to slowly start
cutting away at the clay to get closer
and closer to the final form you know
but you don't want to get the sandpaper
out till you're ready for that like
level of detail work and so it's just
about passes you keep going through it
and once you say I'm gonna start writing
even if you get the page 30 you think oh
page five needs something you just make
a note of it and then zap to the end
before you ever go back so it's it's
really like working it way working
slowly away at that big clay do you no
longer do the isolation retreats I do it
less and less I mean
it's a funny story I was just telling my
son this was when i when i wrote pi my
friend actually who does visual effects
for me his parents had a little cabin up
outside of Woodstock and i was like hey
can i go there for a few days and found
out my muscle draft on pi and he was
like yeah sure and i went up there and
and that his parents were intellectuals
and just had books and books and books
they were academics so there was tons of
books and then i was look you know
procrastinating looking through the
books and of course the only book that
caught my attention was kerry which i
had never read so I proceeded to pound
through procrastinating by reading Kerry
scaring the living crap out of myself
you know when you read King it's just
like wow and then I really had it right
quick cuz I had to get the hell out of
this cabin so I think I wrote the first
gun to pie in like 18 hours Wow
but but to talk about now it's funny
this this this new movie mother is very
very different process that the most
different process than I've ever done
and probably more similar to where I
started I wrote the script in five days
and it was this kind of fever dream when
it happened I had had the idea two weeks
before and you know it started off with
this idea for this allegory with a real
kind of relationship drama at the core
but I didn't know how to structure it
and then I had this kind of breakthrough
of what the structure is and I had a
five-day weekend without my son was with
his mom and I was all alone and I just
sat in my kitchen I actually even go up
to the desk and I just pounded it out in
my kitchen in my on quarter barely
eating it was just like this fever that
came out of me and in five days and when
I was done with the script I showed it
to my producers who didn't know I was
even working on something and they were
like wow wow that I think there's
something here and it's weird I think
I've always been jealous of musicians
you know you hear the story where Bob
Dylan wrote a song in the afternoon and
it became you know the anthem for a
generation but as filmmakers we really
don't get to do that it takes us two to
five years I mean you know Black Swan
the first meeting when Natalie was ten
years before I shot it
the wrestler was eight-years the
fountain took me six years Noah was an
idea for 20 years you know it's a long
time but I was like is it possible as a
filmmaker to take a single emotion and a
feeling of and it's kind of what I was
feeling right in that moment and and try
to channel it into a single track and
into a movie and I think that's kind of
it kind of captures a single emotion
this film even though it has other stuff
it really was one color that burst right
through I want to talk about something
maybe related to fever dream so the the
idea of or concept of madness and I want
to say I'm certainly paraphrasing that
maybe you've said that by walking the
tightrope between sanity and insanity
you can learn what sanity is or
something along those lines
do you have fascination with madness
I mean if so yeah or or why do people
have that perception I had an uncle who
was schizophrenic so I grew up around
that and I got to see it
very very close and sort of saw his
mindset and also how it weighed on my
family and you know the emotional
ripples from that were tremendous and
then I also saw how society treated
people like that and so it's it's
something I've been very close to and
I've always thought about it and I
remember reading I was at the denial of
death you read that book
yeah that's a good one for you but they
talked about the liminal the line the
thin line between the conscious and the
subfloor I think how they were using
between genius and insanity and there
were things that my uncle would say that
I mean he was a highly functioning guy
he worked he worked as an engineer for
New York City for his entire life and
you know had a pension and all that you
know may made it through but lived very
tough tough life because of the illness
but he would say things that were just
unbelievable brilliant like I remember
one time
- my dad was talking to him about
something you know about how to do
something I don't remember exactly the
details and he said well I can't really
say this on radio right oh yeah and he
said something like yeah that's like if
you [ __ ] a snake again an elephant and I
remember hearing it I was whatever I was
12 or 13 but that's kind of a crazy
metaphor and kind of beautiful and it's
so extreme you know it was like the best
way of saying yeah right like you're
selling me the Brooklyn Bridge so but he
had many of those that would just sort
of like that's not proper English and
but it kind of works you know do you
I've always had just absolute
fascination with that very thin line
when I was an undergrad I was I'm not a
mathematician in fact part of the reason
I went to Princeton is because at the
time at least did not have a math
requirement I was scared off of math by
very belligerent teacher in 10th grade
that's not my yeah it was terrible my
brother in fact same grade different
teacher was steered in the opposite
direction and isn't is finishing a PhD
in sociology what teachers can do but I
was drawn to a few specifically
mathematicians at Princeton who were
really riding that razor's edge and had
multiple suicide attempts but were also
brilliant beyond all description yeah I
personally and I in fact also have a
cousin who's schizophrenic which was
relatively later onset and became
effectively a different person still
very smart but have you ever worried
that you would bleed over that edge you
know luckily my hubris doesn't go that
far
get that worried I'm not I'm not I'm not
crazy hyper country I could stuff but
yeah sure I've when I was a yeah I think
when I was a teenager and I read
somewhere that like it like
schizophrenia is onset can happen in
your 20s you know that that idea that
when you're a fully formed human being
sudden like things can change for you
that was a scary idea will it happen for
me but you know I
you know and I definitely think when it
came to you know perhaps exploring you
know plant enhancements I was always a
little terrified that I might go too far
in a certain direction but you know so
it's always been the back of my head a
little bit just cuz you know a lot of
that stuff is genetic but I don't think
it's really haunting me but I guess
maybe a little bit you you thought of
the possibility the fear of it yeah well
I almost off myself in college so I went
through a very very dark period that
actually talked about really publicly in
a major way for the first time on stage
at Ted which really shut them down good
for you it's important but that is
always or has always been kind of in the
back of my mind and one of the things
that I got from as you put it plant
enhancements or psychedelic experience
was temporarily experiencing what could
only be it would have to be on some
level synonymous with extreme mental
illness definitely and having it in
connection and developing more empathy
as a result living in a place like San
Francisco where you're just surrounded
by people who are homeless and mentally
ill so one of the topics I had down to
talk about was psychedelics which was
suggested by someone we both know who
will remain nameless for now but what
role has that played in your life or how
do you think about it as fitting into
your life well I look I think it's I've
researched it read a lot about it I
think it's very interesting I mean you
know the story of deer that in Siberia
that eat mushrooms and fall over and it
doesn't seem like there's any true gin
you know survival of the fittest
evolutionary positivity for a deer to
make itself that helpless so maybe there
is something else going on but some
other medicine or something else that
this creature is getting out of putting
itself at risk
was just a fascinating idea and the fact
that shamanism and reaching alternative
states has been just part of our culture
for a super long time and then somehow
got completely washed out and I don't
know turn into the sacrament maybe rock
and roll music but we've really lost you
know anything that's sort of trying to
reach away from scientific reality is
you know clearly a loss and and it seems
like you know there's a lot of wisdom to
come out of you know some exploration
and in a safe type of examination as
long as very controlled environments
it's as clearly tremendous benefit you
know that's happened you know for
society you know over that's recently
been discovered and is being
rediscovered right now yeah I'm involved
with some researcher Johns Hopkins and a
few other places related to use of cell
Simon specifically in potentially
addressing treatment resistant
depression among other things that's
what's fascinating all that stuff that
Maps is doing with PTSD and the facts of
the Defense Department is supporting it
you know because it seems to be working
you know I just saw a film that came out
of Israel that is using MDMA to sort of
help people deal with not just soldiers
but people deal with all different types
of emotional distress it's fascinating
and it's interesting and it's clearly
you know if the Defense Department is
sort of supporting it then there there's
probably some you know it's probably
pretty interesting to them I think it's
also a really smart place for research
to start or one at least of the subsets
of the population that's very smart to
work with is returning vets yeah
specifically among other reasons because
it is a non partisan issue it's very
hard to be able to [ __ ] the vets yeah or
like screw the terminal cancer patients
who want to increase end-of-life anxiety
it's funny though because another thing
I'm involved with is
on the board of directors for the Sierra
Club and a big part of what sierra club
is trying to do is get vets into nature
you know and they we have all these
different programs that do that in fact
I actually went to the Arctic with two
vets and it was amazing for them to sort
of you know not just to have that
experience which is completely mined
expansive to see you know nature and in
a true to see true wilderness like
what's happening in the Arctic but I
think to a lot of them what they
expressed me is they actually this is
what they were fighting for was the
defendants you know in their their
spirit so they actually get to see the
beauty of America outside of the cities
that they're from so I wanted I want to
continue to talk for a little bit about
really old traditions because what we're
talking about or at least some of these
traditions have existed for millennia
fasting is another one yeah have you
done experiments with fasting a little
bit it's something I definitely want to
get more into I've been totally into the
idea for a long time of course you know
I once a year not that I'm RELIGIOUS but
because I like the spiritual practice of
fasting once a day with my buddies and
so I get together with my friends and
fast for that one day but a long-term
fasting I think is fascinating and I've
heard great stories about it but I
haven't I haven't actually had to it's
amazing how little that goes on and in
our privileged lives and how you know
that's just a very interesting practice
what what is interesting about it to you
because I try to do for instance I try
to do and note to people listening I'm
not a doctor I don't play one on the
internet so don't be stupid talk to a
qualified medical professional bla bla
bla but I've done I tend to do at least
three days of consecutive fasting per
month and then I got longer fasts a few
times per year Wow are you doing just
water I will make some allowances and I
do it differently at different times but
what I will sometimes do is use fasting
as a way to kick-start ketosis so
clicking over
into ketosis certainly our friend Peter
Tia knows a lot about that who's in
ketosis for about two and a half year
straight
but fasting for a period of time and
what I will allow if I'm doing a longer
fast in particular is I will allow
myself non-caloric drinks that are
unsweetened so let's say black tea black
coffee right and KitKat bars and KitKat
bars and I will also particularly in the
beginning allow myself some eggs Oh
Janice ketone so they're just
supplemental ketones or fat like coconut
oil to help with the transition that's
great but besides that amazing Nicks
then the pain is after two three days
right it's supposed to freeze off yeah
for most men women can sometimes take a
little longer to click over for most men
about two to three days and and then you
can then you can click over alright well
let's do it what interests you about the
fasting I mean it once again it's just
the way it's clearly a way to explore
other spaces you know I mean I I
immediately for me if I've got a
difficult meeting where I kind of have
to be a jerk it because something's not
getting done correctly you know if I
skip breakfast and do it close to when
lunch is you know I I get stuff done so
I do in my own way I do I do micro micro
fasting to control my mood knowing that
you know some of that anxiety and anger
will disappear as soon as I eat so it's
sometimes a good thing to sort of motor
might motivate myself to to help with
the work in certain ways so I do do my
own mood enhancement I mean for a long
time you know I was dating someone and
you know we used to get at each other
and then finally someone turned me on to
the word hangry which is the hungry gang
which i think is probably pretty common
now but at the time it was a pretty new
word and i was it kind of changed my
relationship and kept the relationship
going for next 3-4 years because we
could actually identify why we both
became [ __ ] for a little bit so
clearly it's a major move
you know blocker and changer and
alternator and all that stuff so I think
that's interesting and then you know
I've heard and read all about the health
benefits of it and and then of course
there's all the meditative elements of
it to control the mind over the body and
all you know what David Blaine is always
demonstrating clearly going to some
serious extremes but you know I think
there are lessons to be learned and
experiences that we have had had during
it so this is the nature of my
fragmented mind that we're going to jump
around a lot but you mentioned difficult
conversations or where you have to be an
[ __ ] I I had read about well very
very much in passing you having a
conversation with Mickey Rourke before
filming
well Mickey's version yeah so I actually
don't have a whole lot of content but
but roughly that you knew it wasn't
gonna be easy that he had a lot of
strong opinions so you had sort of a an
honest upfront of conversation and I
would love to hear how you open a
conversation like that or plan for it
you know I look you know Mickey at the
time you know had an awful reputation
and I think that's because you know he
you know I I think he in many ways he
was a lot of his worse enemy because he
just you know lot loved acting but he
also loved boxing and you know and he
had this fight and struggle between him
which one he was gonna focus on and you
know I think he you know was he really
respected the box anyway whatever
happened with him you know everyone was
warning me about him everyone but I
loved him and I loved his work
you know before I knew him I just I
thought his work was exceptional and I
it was I felt the crime on the acting
arts that he did not have more
opportunities to share himself with the
world because whenever he has shared
himself
it was unbelievable from barfly to angel
hard to oh that beautiful early work he
did and then it just sort of disappeared
but I just wanted to be very clear with
him because I felt I just knew how
challenging the film we were about to do
was going to be and I just I find that
the longer I do this the more clear you
can be upfront the better because no
matter what happens it always changes I
think sometimes people don't really hear
what you're saying to them a lot because
they really want to do something so I
try to be very very straightforward and
clear because I want to get all the as
many of the problems off the table
because when we do get to set time is
really the biggest enemy or you know foe
because it's so short and and it
happened so quickly that if you start
getting to stupid things that weren't
pretty discussed
it's a nightmare and so you have to be
as completely prepared and professional
as you can when you're spending whatever
it is twenty thousand dollars a minute
or whatever it may be that day you know
you wanna you know Mike Tyson time money
time is what I'm talking about you want
to be on top of your game so I just want
him very clearly with making and I think
I think what it meant for Mickey for is
like he looked at me like medicine
you know he tasted really bad but he
knew it was good for him so you know he
just closed his eyes and opened his
mouth and swallowed to get it done and
and really to keep because I think he
knew deep in his heart that what I was
trying to do was you know make a great
film with him and and then and then he
rose to it and he brought it and and
bring it but you know he talks about
that meeting you know like the little
skinny Punk coming to him and pointing
his little stubby finger in his face
which I love it's funny I wish I was
that tough and that's straightforward
I'm sure I was more cordial and polite
to him because I was I know I was in awe
of him and excited to meet him
but I just wanted to be clear that like
look you know if we're gonna do this
we're gonna do this let's roll up our
sleeves and go for it because it's just
for me filmmaking is so hard I think for
a lot of people there's just so many
challenges it's like you know
literally every single film I've done
has been like its own IPO it sits on
corporation you know I start off with an
idea I have to attract talent and money
to come together yes there's a formula
but I generally are making things that
don't quite fit into the widget factory
they're a little weird and stuff yeah I
don't think they fit though yes so we
have to you know I have to convince
people why it's going to be a widget and
then we have to raise the money and
hopefully you know make it and get to
get the investors monies back and you
know I'm five for six which isn't bad
but you know each time it's it's a real
it's a lot of work so you want to make
the whole process of it for all the
artists working with you as easy as
possible that's not really where you
want to put your fighting you want to do
the fighting for the world and the money
and all that let's say you're making a
new film and you're working with someone
who you respect just to be personalized
a little bit although you could give a
real example let's say like Mickey
someone you really admire who has a
reputation for being very strong-willed
and you're gonna have this conference
and you're gonna have this conversation
again yeah how do you how do you open it
like what is the what are some of the
phrases that you use to prevent it from
blowing up or to to try to allow it to
go well of course I mean look I mean
I've never done a situation where I'm
asking someone hey we're gonna
waterboard you for three months yeah you
know I mean I'm we're trying to do
something that's exciting and hopefully
beautiful and you know you know striving
to make art so that's the underlining
agreement so you're walking into that
conversation hey I dig you you dig me
let's try to make this work
but just to be clear these are some of
the things that are gonna be going on
that will probably make you feel
uncomfortable and what would be some
examples of this you know well I mean a
lot a very clear example would be you
know when working with women if there's
things that or men with those things
that are sexual in nature you know
what's required nudity wise and all that
type of stuff and you have to talk about
that beforehand because of course it's
very sensitive material and you want
everyone to be comfortable and very
clear on why you're doing something you
know I need
we do like a lovemaking scene what
exactly is it going to be and why and
I've never really I've never done a
lovemaking scene to sort of make it sort
of an erotic thing for an audience I
always you know try to tie it in
narrative Lee so I tell them very
clearly where the cameras gonna be what
we're gonna do how we're gonna run the
set stuff like that
same thing with violence you know
violence I think is just as important
and the other way of you know what we're
gonna be how we're gonna be
demonstrating violence how we're gonna
show it I mean for me that's that's a
huge pet peeve because I I feel in this
country you know sexuality and violence
has flipped especially in the movies
where you can have as much violence as
you want in a PG pg-13 movie but you
can't have an ounce of sexuality in a PG
or pg-13 movie and that to me is it's
disgusting I don't have words to go
beyond that the fact that we're you know
training our kids to fire guns at such a
young age with nerf guns and video games
it's disgusting and disturbing while you
know any form of like saying there's a
beauty and human connection physical
connection that no we can't talk about
that
and the fact that the MPAA sort of
reinforces that and and that's what I
mean you know I mean here I'll go off
but like guns in ads I'll walk down the
street when my kid was five six years
old and my kids pointing a huge crazy
sexy looking machine guns on the biggest
movie stars in the world
it's disgusting there the gun companies
are getting free ads and you know yet
you can't show you know someone kissing
you know so there's a whole sort of Bend
with that I don't know how I got there I
don't know how I get to where I go half
the time I want to talk a little bit
about the word catharsis I recently saw
our unit film I really enjoyed the
experience and came away I told you this
for for a full day afterwards was in
this dreamlike state wonderful which I
savored and I had I had a lot of
questions
and sometimes I feel like we well
actually Milan Kundera I think said that
you know people the stupidity of man is
that he has all the answers and the
intelligence or beauty of novels that it
has a question for everything something
like that I'm paraphrasing and this is
in his book of laughter and forgetting
but at one point I recall reading that
you didn't intend people to have to find
catharsis in your movies you know they
they expect to have happy endings and so
on but that perhaps the catharsis comes
the day after seeing the film what do
you want the experience of your audience
to be or what do you want them to take
away from any one of your films you
could give a concrete example or just in
general something that it drives you
well I guess I start off with you know
the first rule of filmmaking is never to
bore an audience that to me is is the
worst feeling and experience when I'm
watching a movie and my mind is
wandering and maybe looking at the color
splatter across the screen I think you
always want to engage an audience not
just visually not just through sound but
emotionally so I think that's rule one
is just to give people an engaging
emotional experience for two hours
whatever your running time is and then I
think on top of that you can hopefully
layer in some ideas so that when people
leave the theater it's not like you know
15 minutes later what what did we watch
you know I don't want to be the
McDonald's of movies where the rapper
you know it's just the rapper is all
that's left over I want people to be you
know thinking a bit about and talking
about it for me one of my best life
experiences was just randomly I walked
into a coffee shop and it happened to be
around the corner from where pie was
playing in LA at the Nuart and a dad
came in with his 18 year old daughter
and two of her friends and the four of
them were sitting there just talking
about this black and white movie that
they had just seen and I just kind of
B's dropped you know listening to him
just thrilled that there was a
conversation and a debate and what did
that mean what did that mean and you
know for me that's always been the
film's I love is you know yes you know
there are movies that you have a
great experience in and enjoy and it's
just a great pleasure to watch and a
great experience but I also like the
ones that you know you know make you
scratch your head and you think about
your talk and your debate because you
know you want to kind of have an impact
and I think in today's landscape a lot
of things are disposable and its really
really quick how disposable they are
because of how quick how much stuff
we're being bombarded with day after day
after day it's nice to sort of hopefully
have something that reflects back on it
thinks about it
you mentioned emotional thinking it's an
emotional connection or engagement what
are the what are some of the ingredients
that help to create that because most
films fail I think anyway yeah I mean I
I mean it starts with the greatest I
think the greatest invention of the 20th
century that's overlooked which is the
close-up and that that's the great thing
about cinema is the fact that you can
stick a camera right in the face of Paul
Newman right and those beautiful blue
eyes and you can go right into his soul
and then when you project it months
later to an audience or years later
potentially centuries later you are
anonymous in that audience yet you can
feel the empathy because in reality two
people talking and hanging out how much
eye contact do you make there's lots of
other things going on in this room that
you're taking in air conditioner
rattling my guys mixing in the other
room but the actual connection with
another human being where you're really
looking into their soul and not thinking
about yourself because the thing is when
I look at you and you look at me we're
thinking a little bit about wow now I'm
making really uncomfortable us looking
at each other and we were gonna be
looking away but in a movie and via the
close-up you can be unconscious and
fully being Paul Newman's head even
though you don't know exactly what
inking you can sort of study him and
steal and steal that thought and that's
that to me is the great greatness of
cinema or one of the great things about
cinema and so and that's where you get
emotion you know and what happens is if
you start linking different emotions
together hopefully you start to tell
story it store what the story does is it
the emotion just like a joke you know
set up set up set up pay off you know
that's the classic structure of a joke
it's the same thing with drama where
you're setting up a character and
building character you give them a
challenge and then you see them go
through that challenge and pay off and
then there's always the pitfall when it
all falls apart and then they rise up
and that that hero's journey you know is
just so I don't know if its genetic I
don't know if it's part of the human
condition I don't know if it's something
that we're taught very very young in our
first dr. Seuss books but it's something
that we all around the planet
in every language and every culture can
relate to and for me the power
storytelling happened I was I graduated
high school early and backpacked around
Europe and the Middle East and I ended
up in the the GEMA in Marrakesh I don't
know if you've been there but it's it's
amazing square in the middle of the the
souk you know where they're all where
they have all the shops and stuff and at
nighttime they had it's filled with
snake charmers and food and all the
stuff and there was one old guy leaning
on a cane and a beard telling a story
and he had a huge crowd around them and
it was all in Arabic and I didn't
understand the freaking word but I was
mesmerised and I was like that's what I
want to do I want to tell stories
because that little old shriveled old
guy on a cane was transforming himself
into this 20-foot beast and I didn't
even understand the language and I was
like that's cool
you know to entertain a crowd with a
point of view where was that experience
relative to your time in Kenya that was
after Kenya I'm also on the board of
directors for organization called the
school for field studies which is a
great organization out of Salem
Massachusetts which basically trains
mostly college students to go abroad and
into sensitive environmental areas and
do environmental studies and when I was
a I don't know a young teenager I
worked at the New York City aquarium in
Coney Island which was right next to my
neighborhood in Brooklyn and the one of
the big perks of that job besides being
at the aquarium was that if you wore the
aquarium t-shirt you got to go on the
cyclone roller coaster over and over
again so we used to go 4050 times in a
row on the side Club you know and but I
picked up a book for the school for
field studies there and they it was just
this little color catalog and I was like
wow they send kids to Kenya and I was
like mom this is what I want to do dad
you know and somehow they took a few
high school students and I was I was
like an advanced biology so I had a
little bit I was always good in cyanide
ad this was a science teacher so I was
always pointed in that direction a bit
and so I got them to let me go to Kenya
where I I did when I study I said he
thermal thermoregulate no I studied
water strategies and ungulates the next
year I went to Alaska with them to
Prince William Sound actually where that
big X on spill was but I was there two
years before that which was fascinating
because the research we did there
actually they used that research after
the after the spill to see what the
impact was but in Alaska I studied
thermal regulation and harbor seals I
just like to say these words because
they're fancy sounding let's no let's
tell us what fall into the class of
ungulates are they're all animals that's
that's down on their hooves so
everything from cattle you know
domesticated cattle to zebra gazelle
yeah there were no deer elk it might've
been some milk and some type of elk
there but yeah so it's all that's true
right I guess they're the caribou in a
last it was interesting we basically
were there we were on this we were on
this ranch owned by an Afrikaner who
wanted to he did this thing called
preservation for profit was his idea
where basically he was like look during
a drought all the cattle died but
indigenous animals of course don't die
because they basically forage in the
morning when there's dew on the leaves
and then the mid afternoon they're in
the shade so basically what we were
there to do is
prove his idea that indigenous animals
were better adapted to the environment
than domesticated animals which is
completely obvious but in science you
have to sort of prove it so we studied
them morphologically which was
biologically when they and then we also
looked at them and their behavior
patterns during the day and I mean it
was fascinating because basically we
just use this you know I learned the
scientific method and we did real
serious research and real charting and
real you know and and the next year was
Alaska when I went to Prince William
Sound and the beauty of that was the
textbook the only textbook we had was
Origin of Species and each every two
days we had to read another chapter of
Origin of Species and discuss it and
over the six seven weeks I was out in
the bush that was the whole whole class
I had read that your time I suppose
acting as a field biologist or doing
field biology in Kenya changed how you
looked at the world now I don't want to
put words in your mouth so I don't know
if that's accurate or not but if that is
true how did it change how you looked at
things
everything changes your life all the
time right but back at that age when
you're 16 and you're Brooklyn kid from
New York City who's basically you know
you know a concrete jungle flea and
you're suddenly in you know the savanna
of Kenya of course it's going to change
your life so it's a little bit of an
overstatement I think but um I mean
every day was mind-blowing I as an
embarrassing moment I was 16 so you have
to forgive me I got off the plane and I
was riding with the professor's to the
thing I was like whoa when are we gonna
see Tigers they're like there aren't any
Tigers in Africa they're in Asia no idea
what was going on so I mean every day it
was just every day literally was
something I had never seen before and
then in Alaska and you know this is a
pre Google pre crazy media age you know
still only eleven channels on the
station a couple of people had cable but
early days of civilization and I
remember we were kayaking it
was an amazing trip it was like five
weeks in kayaks out in Prince William
Sound one of the most untouched places
on the planet at that point until Exxon
showed up and we were going to this
glacier and I had never seen a glacier
now everyone's seen a glacier at this
point because of that the calving ice
and what's happening to the glaciers but
the idea blue ice for a kid from
Brooklyn when I ended like this
Janica glacier or the first time I saw
it it was like 2 miles long
you know half a mile tall I mean I just
with huge chunks of ice falling and
you'd see the chunks fall off and then a
minute later you'd hear the sound
because of the distance like at a
ballpark and then these huge waves from
that start coming at you and you're in a
kayak see really close to water and on
those waves are icebergs which seals
hauled out regulating their temperature
on it going up and down I mean just like
who needs psychedelics you've been
called controversial I don't know if you
view yourself that way but I'd love to
talk a little bit about how to respond
to public perception and criticism
another mutual friend of ours Rick Rubin
fantastic guy incredible music producer
among other a toast yeah he is said on
this podcast he said the best the best
art I'm paraphrasing but the best art
divides the audience and so I think it
was help me out here I think it was
variety the day after you got a 30
minute standing ovation said you should
quit filmmaking I'm gonna have to pee
instead and you've had as anybody who's
in the public arena has a fair amount of
sake criticism of various types yeah
what would your advice be to a filmmaker
you think is very promising who's doing
something that is not that doesn't fit
cleanly in the widget Factory yeah
they're probably gonna catch fire but
they haven't had the experience what
would you say to a person that's an easy
answer keep
you know that's what you want I mean I
when I meet when I teach I like my both
my parents were teachers and so it's in
the blood and I love teaching you know
the thing I try to instill in students
is like the only thing you have to offer
is you you know your individual stories
your individual perception your
individual humanity and figuring out a
way to communicate that humanity to the
humanity at large I mean that's the
beauty of cinema once again that you can
have a six-year-old Iranian girl or 90
year old British gentleman and you can
have an equal emotional experience if
the filmmaker does their job right to it
so like for me it would be you know a
ballerina and a wrestler hopefully can I
make you feel and their blood in their
pain that's that's the goal because
that's you know that that's one of the
great things cinema does is to bring us
into other human experiences so if
you're if it's truthful to who you are
and you're concerned about how people
are gonna react to it you know stick up
your middle finger and charge straight
into that fire you have to if you're
trying to be a provocateur just to be a
provocateur you know go after yourself
you know that to me is that's the bad
stuff is like when it's not real so for
me it's not it's never like oh [ __ ] how
do I you know mess around with that's
not why I make movies at all I I'm just
juiced about these ideas and they had
they have nothing about being
confrontational but even when I do a
film like you know you know the
fountains been called the love poem to
death I pissed people off even though
it's just really gentle move romantic
movie about a guy coming to terms with
dying I guess that's just not a very
commercial idea in the West but you know
III thought it was at the time and I was
like you know dancing around for five
years telling studios I was gonna that
people would be interested in the movie
yeah because I really believed it I
wasn't I'm not interested you know I
happen to be a filmmaker who wants to
talk to audiences I love it I love when
they respond unfortunately I haven't
done a comedy or something that's easy
quite yet easier to connect with an
audience not easier to make by any
I just mean you know when you're going
to when you're aiming the please and
audience it's a lot easier to make it
then when you're just making something
that you feel inside and for me I it's
not a conscious thing it's purely from
my gut that's the core for me it comes
from my stomach always it's not the
heart mostly or it might be somewhere
between I don't know what's right here
solar plexus it's right beneath the
solar plexus it's kind of the stomach I
guess like your large intestine that
area when I feel when I'm writing and
it's like coming out of there I know
it's like it's some type of Chi energy
from there see do you pay a lot of
attention just your kinesthetic response
to what you're doing when you're writing
I mean you see it's that unconscious
state where you're not feeling body
that's the that's the state to get into
we're just coming out of you you know
and and that it's not by aunt by no
means is that often you know I I believe
there are writers out there I was very I
know some real writers and I think they
all right get into that state a lot
easier and but I'm not a real writer but
sometimes I have ideas and that I want
to get out and express and so I I tried
to do it why do you say you're not a
real writer
in there people who would argue you have
writing credits right I don't know I
mean I just I guess I am in awe of I
have I have some friends that really
right and I see the way they can put
words together I don't you know look the
reality I be more truthful with Ferris
than I've been with probably anyone the
reality is I was a public school kid
from Brooklyn and I'd never really
taught me how to write and when I got to
college I went into the creative writing
class and I almost flunked out of it
because I really did not know how to
write an essay I didn't even I to this
day my my son my 11 year old son knows
more about pronouns and nouns and
sentence structure I just never learned
grammar it was never taught to me and
and then and it was a shame I just never
I never did the remiel so I probably
have some type of security about that
because I don't think I could
right that I can write dialogue because
I have an ear and and I and I do have
some ideas that I can try to sketch out
but I don't really you know I guess I'm
scared of I'm scared you're gonna give
me an essay to write that's gonna be a
challenging I'm gonna be the last person
write my my writing my senior thesis in
college which is mandatory and it
constitutes a huge part of your
departmental grade for the entire time
that you were at school traumatize me so
much that I pledged to myself when I
graduated I would never write anything
longer than an email ever again clearly
did not work out it worked out but it
didn't work out as planned I guess what
was your thesis on my thesis was on the
phonetic and semantic acquisition of
Chinese characters in the Japanese
language called kanji by native English
speakers
uh-huh so how do native English speakers
most effectively acquire both the
meaning and pronunciation of Chinese
characters unbelievable yeah in
retrospect this doesn't seem like
someone who's afraid of writing would
write something like that that's pretty
you know I had I had a lot of my true
interests were buried in some of these
early writing projects or even
scientific assignments that I then felt
were trivial or not serious for some
reason and now I'm coming back to them
20 years later I mean nothing I remember
I took a neuroscience class initially
the plan was to be a neuroscience major
actually was a psychology major focusing
on neuroscience for a host of reasons
moved to the language acquisition namely
principally I couldn't do the animal
testing that was required to be part of
the lab I want to be part of I'm not you
yeah I mean I will say I mean I
understand the sensitivity of the
subject I do think some studies are very
difficult to do or impossible to do
without certain animal modeling but let
me just say that for instance one of the
studies I I've been deep into this know
I know
I know I don't want to know now for
environmental reasons just I know for
sure I have a we'll talk about it later
no we can't yeah we can definitely talk
about the but where I became I was
really fascinated by REM sleep and some
of the the physiological similarities to
states that can be induced with
hallucinogens
and so this was probably my sophomore
year in college that I was really
fascinated by this and it only took 20
years 25 years to come back to it full
circle did you ever try to stay awake
for a long time I stayed awake and this
is not advisable disclaimers well you
know because every once in a while I get
an email from somebody that my cousin's
dead he gave himself a headache and I'm
like yeah you gotta use your common
sense people but I stayed away for six
days oh wow
I wanted to see what would happen
because I had read these reports of
people having all sorts of odd
phenomenon crop up when you stay awake
for that period of time and so I used
stimulants nothing illegal right what
was very good at concocting put any of
these cocktails for myself and stayed
awake for six five and a half six days I
stopped because I was walking on campus
I remember very clearly where I was I
was I was I fell asleep while I was
walking and woke up about a block later
a while and I had crossed or throw oh
wow and I was like you know what this is
no longer a good idea but you have you
stayed awake for a really long time yeah
no I had a it was a test when I was in
undergrad and my roommate did it where
he basically was to stay awake and he
just became cruel and I remember him
tell me like they they were like he's
like I never sleep like don't go to
sleep so he took a deck of cards and
started throwing cards around the room
and made everyone run around and pick
him up otherwise he would go to sleep so
he started doing like really messing
with the AIDS and and the grad students
they were doing the study side
yeah but of course the overnighter and
those are important not just you know
when you're in college and stuff but I
haven't I'm glad you are out there
exploring it for us yeah I don't the
conclusion is don't do that yeah
the conclusion is don't do that and if
you remove sleep and food from people
they get really really grumpy it turns
out this is a quote from New York
magazine this may have been from a while
ago I don't think it's that old actually
so I think when I was starting out as a
filmmaker I had tremendous focus but I
don't think I robbed myself of too much
life I'm still friends with the guys I
grew up with in nursery school I have a
great leash my family I'm definitely
attracted to balanced symmetry I'm
definitely an ordered personality but
I'm a lot less ordered than I was
goddamn I said some stupid [ __ ] you can
correct the record straight
but this is of incredible interest to me
because many people who would aspire to
be creative or who self-described as
creative run themselves out or they they
sacrifice family relationships by being
singularly focused and sometimes they're
proud of it sometimes they regret it
yeah but this is this is something that
I don't hear very often yeah so I was
wondering if you could just elaborate on
that because how do you have how do you
have the tremendous focus required to do
what you've done while still having that
balance and symmetry I mean it it is a
balancing act and you know but I think
all the time you put into life you know
into family and into friends and into
activities outside of the work you know
back to our procrastinate not saying you
know what your family is procrastination
but bringing in those other experiences
into your life is what makes you be able
to relate to people and to communicate
and at least for filmmaking that's a
major part is you know
going to a diner with friends and seeing
an argument between some strangers over
there ends up in a movie for me you know
living life and seeing stuff and doing
all different types of experiences
through this planet is important to be a
storyteller because it's all about the
stories I mean I think the first three
four films of my career and definitely
all my short films before that all came
out of very personal experiences of my
life and and the problem is if you keep
working non-stop
and your originating your material I
think it's different if you're more of a
journeyman who's going along and then
just taking your craft and bringing it
to life bringing a great script to life
because what do you mean by that as a
journeyman what something that's not a
personal story by nature I mean I think
every story's personal or you can find a
personal way because anytime you portray
a character on screen you should sort of
infuse them with real emotions and stuff
so and to do that you have to feel it
yourself but if you're drawing on your
own life and your own stories and you're
somehow more autobiographical somehow
even through metaphor because I think
all my films are not about I'm not a
ballerina yet you know there's a lot of
Natalie in me I mean that character Nina
and me not Natalie but Nina the
character I'm not a wrestler but I Randy
the RAM I I'm pretty connected to and I
understand why he makes every decision
and some of those stories in there I can
relate to or are drawn from my own life
so I think you know if it's an
assignment where you don't really you're
just showing up as a director and you're
there to you know make all the
departments work together and make the
actors do it I think it's the it becomes
it becomes more of a craft then not to
say that it's not art but I think if
you're trying to create your own stories
that are coming out of life you have to
actually live life to do it you know
otherwise you're just getting your
stories I don't know where you could get
your stories from I guess you can make
things about being an obsessive Phil
which is kind of like you know when my
favorite filmmakers Fellini started
making films about directors making
films
you know or you know yeah yeah I mean
eventually went off and tell the things
but for a while that's what he worked on
and so I think you you have to balance
in this in this art form it's it's very
different I think in different forms
because other forms can be expressed in
different ways so I can't really speak
for that but a but storytelling you need
stories remise if something has told at
one point which helped me at least which
was a friend of mine writer I think it
was it might have been it was either
Debbie Millman I want to say her Maria
Popova and they said if art imitates
life you have to have a life and I guess
my follow-up question is when you are
really immersed in a project yeah and
maybe maybe now with family and so on
it's different than in the early days
but my experience and part of the risk I
have when I go into a project is that it
tends to crowd out other things right
you schedule say time with friends and
family so that they don't get displaced
how do you ensure that that happens or
you just program in such a way that it's
natural it's not a bad life as a
filmmaker because it basically at least
the way my my schedule is I do a film
every two three years so in that 2-3
years they'll be like a 50 60 day run
which will be completely selfish and
completely committed and dedicated to
the film where I'm working 18 20 hour
days over and over again insane amount
of time and you know you get one day off
on the weekend and then the next day
you're probably prepping although I'm
able now to almost get two days off
because I've been doing it enough that I
kind of have more skills that I can go
in so I can get a weekend off sometimes
but where I can spend with family and
friends not that I could go out and
party and have a beer I mean it's got to
be very mellow and most of the time I'll
just want to watch Game of Thrones but
that's a huge marathon that only happens
once every two three years and then you
get into editing and it's basically a 95
job
you know there's always things coming up
but it's a much slower pace and that
could be a 40 week process then you get
to selling the film which is kind of a
two three week kind of marathon of
travel but it's kind of fun because
that's where a lot of stories come from
because you see all these different
cultures and you just see a lot of crazy
[ __ ] so it's not that bad and then and
then I get into development and when I'm
in development for the next project it's
once again I can really shape that
around my son's schedule and and and I
can have time to see my friends and have
experiences and travel and stuff like
that because when you're developing it's
all virtual virtual in your head not
quite in a computer but it's it's all in
your imagination for a while and all you
need is a notepad and a pen and you
could be anywhere are there any
particular resources and I'm sure this
is a question you've had a lot so I
apologize in advance but I haven't heard
the answer so to aspiring filmmakers
let's just assume intelligent driven
organized so big assumption but let's
just assume they check those three box
sure are there any particular books or
resources or approaches that you would
suggest they take assuming that they're
they want to put together some type of
narrative storytelling about doing a
document yes sir I always push the
writers journey by Christopher Vogler
it's very good but it's only for people
who are writing screenplays so butty but
he's great he basically took Joseph
Campbell's work and turned it into
screenplay language and he did a really
good job at it and we're totally part of
his cult because we I believe in that
hero's journey and not say that's the
end-all endl and there are other ways to
approach it but it's a very very
interesting structure that can really
lead to big breakthroughs when you're
struggling you can look at the different
archetypes that there are and and often
you find yourself falling into it and
you know it's funny like requiem for a
dream when I was working on it
I I it was before I read Vogler but now
that I look back I I still I was doing
stuff similar where I was charting out
where their emotion was the characters
and what was interesting is that the
graph was actually upside down when
something good was supposed to happen
something bad was happening and I was
looking at it and one day I flipped it
over and I said oh they're actually the
bad guys all my characters the good guy
is addiction and this is actually a
hero's journey of addiction overcoming
the human spirit that's when I finally
understood what the movie was about and
charting it and using hero's journey is
how I was able to figure out that bad
idea out that this invisible monster was
this craving was actually the hero of
the film but that's great I mean and
then the other thing back on what we
talked about is you know tell tell your
story don't try to figure out what
people want because the reality is you
know and I kind of learned this when I
when I was coming out of film school I
went to support my friend Scott silver
who's a big screenwriter now have made
of directed a film that was at Sundance
and it was the year that welcomed the
dollhouse was there and a bunch of other
indie gems and I remember watching these
films go these are such specific unique
movies but they're done exquisitely well
and what Sundance allowed me to believe
in what independent film has allowed so
many dreamers to believe is that if you
make a film well no matter how personal
it is if it's truthful you'll find an
audience so not not to invoke the name
of Rick again but I was having a
conversation with with Rick recently in
a barrel sauna that is the exact replica
of his barrel sauna and we were talking
about this deadline that I continually
I'm actually working hard on the book
but I spent a lot of time talking
talking about how hard I'm working on
the book and I was asking him some
questions about working with musicians
and whether he knows if something has
hit the mark or not and I'm gonna
paraphrase here but he said effectively
great is always better than now and
that's and and then the way I
interpreted that was you know there's
always a good time for great there's
never a good time for me do occur so if
you feel like you've rushed to hit some
kind of deadline obvious there
realities of production and so on don't
get me wrong but yeah you can't rush you
can't rush that's you know I mean bricks
filled of wisdom yeah and it always
comes out so interesting but yeah I get
that it's you can't force it the thread
I want to tease a little bit is
something you mentioned earlier which is
say the argument between the stranger is
that in the diner that then makes it
into your movie right could you tell us
or tell me since I'm just sitting right
here yeah about you were your history
with the game of Go I got into it a lot
when I was doing pie I needed a game for
the two guys to be playing so that they
had some reason that they were meeting
so that Max and his mentor could meet
and I just thought playing chess was
just we've seen it so much and it's
cliche and mathematicians playing chess
was just not quite interesting enough
and at that point 97 go was still very
much a fringe game sort of is still and
but I think it was much more fringe then
and we used to go a lot to the the New
York go chapter meetings which were like
18 very intellectual people in very book
line departments at different houses
each week playing go so it was a great
cast of characters justify and they that
you know the best thing about go
character go characters are the ones
that have said that blow off chess as
like a fool's game
you know they so look down on just such
a chip on their shoulder the faith they
graduated to go but that you know
another thing that's fascinating that
I've been hearing a lot of people I
think actually Rick was talking me about
it that's where I heard it was he's when
I suggested I asked you oh there you go
but the documentary which I haven't seen
yet he told me there's some documentary
about what it meant
this computer finally beating these go
masters and he was telling about a scene
where after the first move the go master
gets up and like walks away because
basically I guess the point was that
it's such a radical way to change of how
the game is played how this computer is
playing it that it's actually affecting
now how humans play each other well
that's that's a line about AI that is
interesting where you know it actually
changes the way we act with each other
after thousands of years of playing a
game a certain way suddenly this idea
comes that is a moment of genius that
changes the way we look at the board
that was interesting idea and that is
that from a dot that's from a document I
believe so but yep that's my last
because I fascinate me and I I was I've
been thinking about it for Oh see that
yeah I don't want to take us totally off
the rails but I'd like oh I have a go
board at my house I'm not good yeah I
tend to play a highbrow version of
Connect for which hello Connect five I
will my brother and I love to play we
just call it Connect five or something
like that where we use a go board and it
seems really childish but my brother's I
mean he's he's a statistics PhD very
good chess player and these games can
actually last a really really low so
it's just basically getting five in a
row and you could place them anywhere on
the board sounds great yeah it can it
can take you don't flip on tiles or
anything it's just about blogs right you
leave them there so you're not capturing
well you are capturing territory but the
rules are completely different from real
go yeah my son came home from math class
with fat on paper and we played it for a
while and I was like wow this is
complicated game super complicated and
go is so fascinating on many many levels
one of which is you can feel like you're
winning and then effectively if you're
if your pattern recognition is off in a
handful of moves completely lose I mean
it's it the tide can turn a lot faster I
shouldn't say this with any degree of
ability because I know people like Josh
Waitzkin are actually good at just I'm
not but the the game I got really into
in Japan so my first trip abroad was a
year in Japan as an exchange student at
a Japanese school lived with a Japanese
family and I listened to the session you
did with the knife maker Marie Carter
Marie is amazing so I want to get
some of his knives are incredibly good
they're so good
the muteki lion-o his stuff is amazing
so the game I got into was called shogi
so shogi is Japanese chess oh wow and
what makes Japanese just different and
there are ways you can play western
chess this this way what you're able to
reuse the captured pieces interesting
and just drop them on the board at
different places and then also not only
do pawns get promoted there are multiple
pieces that turn into completely
different pieces very full when they get
supposed to sort of chess yeah it's
really a cool game and so there's a I
used to buy these books in Japan yeah
su-mei shogi su-mei shogi is uh
basically books that allow you to like
think of a really slow app it's a book
where you you try to figure out the
three or four moves in a given position
necessary to win the game and then
there's an answer key and so I would on
the subway she have a lot of time on the
subway in Tokyo just I did I would
either read comic books or I would look
at these semi show he or Audrey Juneau
text books but I'm giving judo yes
as an aside it's funny why I it was very
upsetting when they got a Wi-Fi on the
New York City subway because now I have
to work hard but like my rule is never
take out your phone not because I'm
worried about getting stolen or anything
but just because that's the chance to
watch people for me and so you don't
want to get lost in your device at that
point it said that's the great time and
the rule New York is great you know
basically you can stare at anyone you
want if they make eye contact with you
you can never look at them again but
you're allowed to look as long as they
don't look at you and that's that it
people come New York I said that's early
you can you can watch and check each
other out but if they realize you're
being checked out stop so I I find it
fascinating and I imagine
yeah the subways in Japan must be insane
it's just yeah once again you know well
what what shocked me but I mean there's
so many things that are so alien about
Japan for someone who hasn't been
exposed you know to Japan specifically
even in East Asia and I've spent time in
China I've gone to school there I've
spent time in Taiwan
Japan Japan and within Japan Tokyo is
just that particularly a particular
brand of weird and so you get on the
subway and I remember a couple of things
really striking me some 15 everything is
backwards right we're driving on the
opposite side of the street like we have
to take a shower before we get into the
bath and like all these rules that seem
very Alice in Wonderland topsy-turvy
yeah and then I sit down on the subway
and you'll see you know these salary men
Saturday mom or on their way to work
these worker bees and they're reading
comic books with the most explicit horn
imaginable and they're completely
nonchalant about it yeah I mean tentacle
porn who knows and then the the other
hilarious phenomena I bumped into which
I'd really didn't expect to hear about
in Japan perverts on the subways and
they're definitely perverts on the
subways and they're called Chi cung so
if you're like gee can't she go that
means a pervert / / / Lou and so if like
some guys trying to fondle some girl's
ass like you look here chica and then
there's a big kerfuffle what they don't
tell you is that remember one day I was
an icon and kerfuffle and one sentence
just so you know might be the first the
singularity is near and I was in my
school uniform 15 clearly a high school
student right have my Judy uniform over
my shoulder it's wrapped up and I'm
standing up as packed subway and I fear
I feel someone groping my ass oh wow and
I'm like what is going on here I can't
turn around it's so crowded
yes geez and eventually I'm old turn
around and what do I see not what I
expect I see two really old women with
like half of their teeth with Captain
gold chuckling to themselves because
they've been grabbing my ass and these
women are called Obata young so Obata
young is from old battalion which it's a
long story but it refers to like older
Japanese women who just don't give a
[ __ ] yeah oh really my favorite you
know when I went to Japan for the first
time which was with PI you know I was I
was a big huge fan
I had all I dreamt for so long I go to
Tokyo and I was like you know I kind of
I want kind of want to make a statement
here I kind of you know I want to be
remembered you know come with us a
little film what can I do so I dyed my
hair purple and I came and I do an
interviews the whole time with big
bright purple hair and no one mentions
it and I get to my last interview and
it's kind of a young hip guy who's like
a pop star in Japan and we become
buddies and I'm like and you know like I
made my hair purple but no one's
commenting on it he goes yeah come to
the window we look out silence what
major intersection says who has purple
hair out there all the old ladies
hi there that's totally true oh my god
that's true having flashbacks I think
the old ladies are it's like you know in
requiem for a dream they dyed their hair
red and it's purple so speaking of
tentacle porn this is that's about as
graceful a segue as I can make and we
don't have to talk about this if you
don't want to but this is one of the
bullets that was recommended for me to
talk to you about and I should preface
this by saying in my second book for our
body there are two chapters on female
orgasm two on various aspects of male
sexuality so I'm not shy about talking
about this but recently I'm on the
Howard Stern suddenly you're in the
Howard Stern Show restricting
ejaculation I don't have any context for
this when I was told to ask you about
restricting ejaculation Wow where'd you
get that from
my sources can but is that something
that you can tell us about I'm not sure
what you're referenced oh oh I think oh
there we go
I bet it's coming back to me it was
funny I had it I had a well visit in
requiem for a dream there's something in
the background called month of fury
which was I guess it was early self-help
I had a I when I wow this is going way
back and actually kind of flows a little
bit into probably why
we're growing friendship is happening
here because similar roots in a certain
way but when I my first when I was in
film school and there's another great
thing for young film students to know is
like there's usually the first
screenplay you write that will never get
made and believe me that happens and at
some point you have to be you take the
bold step to abandon it you know because
there's a learning process in that first
script and I worked on the script that
was set in Coney Island and I had a guy
a really talented kid I grew up with who
probably if you went to Wall Street
would be a you know a hundred
millionaire type of guy but he ended up
getting involved in this kind of cult
the organization that are those guys who
go around and sell roses and little toys
around the streets wearing ties I don't
know if you ever see them there are a
lot on the west coast and they they're
basically kind of pyramid schemes where
you basically open up an office and you
hire like 10 20 year-old kids and they
go and they hustle for you and then you
buy it from a guy above you and if you
get a few you slowly move up this type
of thing and they have these huge
conventions in Vegas with where they all
come together and they have all these
chants where they juice each other up
and get all excited and I when I was in
film school he was in the West Coast
area and so I just sort of studied it
and hung out with him once again here's
another play hang out with a friend but
also kind of get stories so I developed
this whole kind of characters in world
for this movie about this and eventually
I didn't make that film but I was able
to take that character and and when I
had to bring Hubert Selby juniors
requiem for a dream alive sour Goldfarb
the old lady watched a lot of TV but we
couldn't afford the TV to put TV on the
channel so I decided to make my own TV
show and create and create kind of a
Tony Robbins esque because Tony was just
starting and it was he he didn't sort of
evolve into the kind of figure he is now
at the time he was sort of a tell event
and it was it was odd so I kind of
created my own sort of version of that
and had this guy on TV and I had to give
him a philosophy so I had an act of
friend who was also a boxer and he had
this thing called monpa fury
eddie de harp as his name
and there was three rules which are
actually three great rules it was 30
days no refined sugar 30 days no red
meat and 30 days no orgasm now those
altogether yeah I do all three for a
month for 30 days and it was actually a
very interesting you know so so he
preached it to me because he would do it
before he would boxer won't worry dad no
refined sugar no refined sugar so that's
everything like toothpaste anywhere
where there could be sugar you know no
red meat and then no orgasm so in the
movie requiem for a dream the third one
is not actually pitched because I just
thought it would be good as a little
secret now I'm sort of giving it away
although it's come out of it it's it's
actually in there it's actually in there
a bit it's an easter egg that's hidden
in the film somewhere it was funny
because when you know when we started
working on it
I suggested to the actors that they
should go on a month of fury before we
make the movie just to understand what
it is to withdraw which is a big part of
the movie because it's hard if you're
not a drug addict or a smoker you know
to actually stops something for 30 days
to fast as you talked about - it's it's
really tricky and here with three things
that's were seemingly not hard to do and
it was funny to you know run and see my
actors at day 24 and 25 wanting to kill
me you know
hence the month idea yeah and I have
another friend my best buddy who
actually on day 29 ended up proposing to
a woman which I was like 29 what are you
out of your frickin mind the month of
peering about the fury of it so if I
ever did a self-help that would be you
know hey if you want to co-write it and
start a movement
I know you carry your first folks
I could I could get I think quite a few
people to participate in the most
furious actually very effective I'd love
to ask quite a few questions about the
new film but the first is related to the
writing of the film hmm so when you are
writing a film like mother and there are
many and I don't wanna give anything
away but
many visual components how do you write
that type of material being the writer
and then the director I can sort of not
worry about that that much but there are
two different steps
I think first you're writing and you're
following along the emotional truth of
the characters and following scene by
seeing what's going on and watching the
story unfold and then there's the next
stage at a certain point you kind of
hang up most of your writing cap because
you can always rewrite if you're the
writer but then you start to become the
director and start to think about
blocking and movement and that was a
very very big deal in this film can you
define blocking just for people who
don't know lobbying it yeah sure
blocking is basically just how actors
move in a scene that's all it is but
it's really truly a big part of the work
because for a lot of reasons first you
want to create blocking that's organic
and natural to what the actors are doing
in the scene so you want to make sure
whatever the actors doing makes sense
with what their objective is in the
scene or what they're doing in this you
know what they're not doing in the scene
or what they're hiding in the scene so
you kind of want to think about what
that what that is all about then there's
a second tier which is as the filmmaker
you're trying to make it as economical
as possible meaning as few setups as few
times to move the camera as possible
because every time you have to sort of
change where the camera is you have to
change the lighting and that just takes
time and you want to get as much time
being shooting as possible so you're
trying to figure out blocking that works
best for the simplest amount of
technical problems unless you're really
trying to do something technically super
challenging stuff so you try to balance
those and you know you and it's kind of
a balance because sometimes you'll tell
the actor oh can you help me out here
with blocking because it means we have
to do less but sometimes you don't want
to get in their way and you want them to
be creatively free so you want to give
them an open playground to play around
and where they can do and move so it's
all it's it's it's a balancing act but
but it's a big part of it so at a
certain point you know when the script
is done and in the case of mother I was
actually lucky enough to have a three
and a half month rehearsal period where
basically I convinced Jennifer Lawrence
and Javier Bardem and Michelle Pfeiffer
and Harris to join me in a warehouse out
in East Brooklyn where we basically
taped out the set and got we would work
on the scenes and we get up on our feet
and we would just start to block them
and then in the last two weeks of that
three and a half month long process I
actually brought in my cameraman and we
shot the entire movie moving the camera
around on video as kind of homework and
then which was really fascinating
because you figure out all different
types of problems like Oh how's the
camera gonna get from its it's a
constant moving hand-held camera so how
am I gonna get the camera from here to
there because there's a wall there and
and that's that suddenly started to play
into action and for this film it was a
very very restricted visual language I
was part of the one of the challenges I
put in front of myself normally you'll
have a wide shot in a movie and nice
thing about a wide shot is if an actor
somehow does something that's not that's
like dramatically new emotionally new or
if they decide to comb their hair a
different way in each take if you go out
to a wide shot the basically the the
illusion has broken from them because
the viewers eyes have to take in more or
different part of a scene or there's
other things to look at so that when you
pop back into a close-up you can get
away cheat almost
what's happening and no one would ever
notice in the case of my film since
there was no wide shots it was extremely
challenging I mean the only shots in the
film are you the over Jennifer
Lawrence's shoulder on Jennifer
Lawrence's face or her point of view
which means what she's looking at that's
the only coverage in the entire film so
that's why this edit has been you know
almost a year-long cut because I had
such a limited amount of language to
work with and I had to make every moment
by moment by moment work even though
that's not really happening in real time
why did you choose to use that
constraint I find
I feel like I could talk to you about
constraints and rules for a really long
time yeah because you mentioned Jerry
yeah exactly
just get progressively more belligerent
and you talked about say having lunch
scheduled for after the difficult
meeting and then you have say shooting
over Max's shoulder yeah yeah yeah and
different ways of as you put it sort of
limiting year yeah usual pallet why do
that well I think I think coming out
starting as an independent filmmaker
with very limited resources makes you be
very very you know try your
strategically you have to figure out
economical means to basically take
advantage of all the limited resources
you have so I ended up actually
stylistically creating techniques that
actually are turn those that limited
economics into a stylistic choice so
I've always been preaching that
boundaries are the most important thing
in any form of an art you know I mean
when you're a painter you have the
boundaries of a canvas and the
limitation of your of the your colors
and I think it's extremely important to
do the same in filmmaking and and and to
make real choices about how you want to
do those limits sometimes they're
self-imposed that I have less of the
economic issues although always you have
to be very economically responsible for
it for what you're doing but I went
really extreme on this film which was
like I basically said there's three
shots for every scene which is an
incredibly low amount of shots but I
would normally do in a movie and it just
became an interesting exercise and
experiment you know and there were times
when Maddie my DP was like don't you
wanna you know like never does a
character come between Jennifer and the
camera yeah no one never crosses the
land I noticed that which is crazy
because when we're doing crowd scenes
with lots of people you know it would be
a lot easier to tell the story by having
Jane get lost in the crowd and crowd
come through but no I was like I'm my DP
Matt he was like wow it could be and we
talked about it for a while
and I was like no I think let's just
remain Orthodox here let's remain
truthful to the intent and the one thing
I was worried about people would feel
claustrophobic or you know bored by the
style and that doesn't seem to be the
response people aren't seeing those
limitations and I think that's because
we just turned it into a language and
into a style that people can understand
is there something you hope audiences
will respond with or walk out with did
you have an objective and this ties into
I suppose the the genesis of the film's
well I don't actually know the origin
story
well the origin story is hard because
it's murky I think it came out of these
endless headlines
the endless stream of notifications on
your telephone the ability to scratch
right beneath the surface of our kind of
civilization and realize how many
desperate and awful things are happening
around the planet still in this you know
pretty enlightened time and there's a
lot of rage and a lot of helplessness
because like what can I do how can I
stop this and you know being an
environmentalist when we're completely
under assault when you know what science
is telling us is going on and the same
people that use our smartphone every
second and every minute of the day of
the people who say well science isn't
always right yet this the product of
science is in their pocket you know
dominating their lives yet refusing to
see what's going on like how could you
not say wow there might be some
connection going on and I don't know I
come from a science background and III
witnessed how little tiny small changes
by man can deeply have huge effects very
quickly that are out of control you know
and then this new idea of these feedback
loops which isn't that new anymore but
these ideas that are becoming more idea
that there's these tipping points where
things are just gonna start to
accelerate you know and as a parent I
just sit there and I go oh my gosh you
know I look at the beauty of my child
and want them
get about having a job having a freakin
atmosphere and having the ability to I
mean it's just crazy to ever think you
know he'll see a really an elephant in
the wild and in any type of wilderness
way I mean III for the fur I guess I
guess Prince William Sound was very much
wilderness when I was a kid and and
something happened to me when I was in
Prince William Sound that was I had a we
were kayaking as I said for weeks and I
was eating a granola bar and the wrapper
fell into the water it was like a foil
wrapper and I freaked out I like stopped
I tried it just went right under and
because of that guilt of that I still
when I see trash on a beach I pick it up
for that foil you know it's like that
that guilt has carried me and I because
at that time it very much felt untouched
like I was the one of the first humans
to ever experience it there isn't a
place on the planet anymore not because
of pollution only but because of climate
change that isn't affected by humans
there is nowhere on the planet that is
true wilderness as it was 60 years ago
you know when I was I was writing a
Western and I realized you know it was
said in 1883 I think if every single
person on the planet disappeared dropped
dead was abducted or whatever at that
point in time besides some forged metals
belt buckles horseshoes bullets guns
everything every remnant of humanity
would be gone in a century you know
completely gone because everything was
built out of Earth materials and then
you suddenly have all these freakish new
materials where every single bag of
Lay's potato chip you have is something
that's around for 10,000 years longer
particles that are part of us and you
can't escape it and so quickly from my
childhood where there still was places
on the planet that weren't really
feeling any impact to now where the it's
all changed it's it's scary that people
are just completely denying it and
turning their backs on it and out of
that just you know I just want a howl
it's like you know I felt the Ginsberg
Hal and I just wanted how and I guess
it's my house
what is the Ginsberg hell Allen
Ginsberg's the poem how got it alright
sorry I never rang my lack of it you do
show that one you sure you know what's
great all right yeah I mean but it's
basically you know it was a cry from the
60s you know like what for his
generation or at least that's the way I
took it how would you like people to go
into the movie and who should go see
them like now now the obvious commercial
answer might be everyone well I think
look I think you gotta know you're going
into a rollercoaster ride and it's like
you know when you get to the amusement
park and you see that loop-de-loop and
you're like no freakin way you should
hop you should be ready for it
I mean you know and no matter how much I
prep you and Tim can tell you it goes
there so right yes it's intense and it's
very okay
so if you want an intense different ride
if you're you know you want to see
something different at the at the cinema
you know please come on down I I think I
think it's I you know that's what we
tried to do was make make a very unique
roller coaster except you know it may go
off the tracks and into the concrete
wall but I can't really be I don't want
to be responsible for that but that's
what I happens but I I mean I just want
it I think it works on a lot of levels
um I was always like thinking it was
gonna be really scary and and you know
tilting into the horror genre you know
Jen Lawrence when she saw it actually
thought it was incredibly beautiful and
moving that there was a beauty to it and
and then and I've heard that reflected
in a lot of ways and so it's definitely
not your normal night at the movie it's
it's but it's the type of movie that you
go see and and everyone will have
something to say about it
I think and hopefully they're not too
many profane words directed in my
direction well it could be profane but
modifying something good also there's
that yeah I'd like to ask about the
sound yeah so I I have read that well a
few things that a a lot of independent
films or films in general fail from poor
audio yeah
that was a big thing I realized very
young and my career was like there's a
pretty good movie but something's off
and it was always a sound and the sound
in this movie and in Elena I mean in in
more than one of your films certainly is
very I'm searching for the right words
but very visceral very pronounced and I
only read this other expression after
the fact after I saw the movie but then
I think thinking of music or the sound
as as an additional character yeah could
you elaborate on that
because I've never paid so much
attention yeah a sound in a film I think
it's well you saw a slightly unfinished
only the first half the film was kind of
really dialed in so it's gonna get
better
I hope that's what we're supposed to be
doing as we speak you know sound
designed it for me as a huge tool and I
got totally turned on when I was a young
kid I saw a documentary on the guys who
did the sound design for Star Wars and
they were out in the desert banging on
wires making light saber sounds and it
blew my mind I was like wow you know
that's such a cool idea that you can use
any sound to do this and matching up
sound an image you can really mess
around so I've always been fascinated by
that but you know since I make these
films where I really am trying to make
the audience have a visceral experience
with the character in this case Jennifer
Lawrence's character I try to draw the
audience into a subjective point of view
by you know creating a soundscape that
starts off realistic but then as things
sort of shift and get more and more
insane becomes more and more expressive
and expressionistic I love the fact that
people are going to be able to see this
in theaters for a lot of reasons and I
want to connect this to something else
that I read about you which relates to
the historical lack of compliance to
widget making so the story of you
shooting Natalie Portman for Black Swan
in the subway at something like 3:00 in
the morning without necessary permits
without her having signed a contract
how do you and I don't know it nearly as
many filmmakers as you do but I know a
few yeah how do you get away with it
I mean you meaning you seem to be able
and this is from the outside looking in
yeah but to make the art you want to
make and bend the rules or do things
like that why is that
are there certain sort of contractual
decisions or conversations you've had
that allow you to do it did you set the
precedent as like a problem child early
so that's they're just like that's
[ __ ] Darren so you get away with it
I mean it's just the project I I don't
think you know it's never meant to be
abusive but I'm just saying I think
that's the reality is it's it's not
abusive it's about the work it's always
about the work and I think if you can
relay back to that but it is this is
about you know us bringing this to life
in the best way and I think you know
there are people that would take that
line of argument and turn it into abuse
or or push the line to something that's
not safe or fair and I think I'm pretty
empathetic to other people's feelings
maybe to a fault
because I think some directors may it's
kind of helpful sometimes to push past
some of that pain and be blind to it but
that's never that's just not my
character I can't do it I feel when
people are uncomfortable very easily and
it makes me probably better as a
director to read performance but it
probably gets me less than what I always
need because I feel sorry sometimes I
have mercy yes and how dare you so yeah
but but you know I think though that you
know when it's the work you you just you
go for him people get excited by that
and if you're actually being truthful
about that it's but there are times and
places where I've tried to do too much
and people pointed out to me hey that's
probably you know it's not fair for
these reasons and I hear that and and
then I just listen to myself if that's
the truth or not if you have that
conversation and doesn't feel true to
you is that the is that one of the
primary causes of walking from potential
projects or
like what and I guess all of this is
sort of coalescing into a question of if
you were talking to a very promising new
director let's say director maybe
they're a writer director but they
direct and you wanted to prevent them
from getting chewed up or corrupted by
the system is there any particular
career advice that you would give to
them it's a good question I mean I mean
you know just you got to be doing if I'm
always from the school you got to do it
because you have to do it but you don't
have any other choice but to do it just
recently I ran into a filmmaker and he
was sort of complaining and whining
about doing a TV show because he really
wanted to be making films and that the
and then but you know what my advice to
him was not just stick with your gut and
do what you want I could tell he was the
type of guy that should be doing that TV
show because I could see like he was he
was already past that point where he had
crossed and he was just gonna so I was
like do it but I but then you find
people who just you know want to do what
they do and you know and then you just
want to support them and give them as
much love and support to to get it
because they're trying their hardest to
do something that only they can do now
does that mean since I've heard this
advice with writing that writing you
should only write say a book if it's
easier for you to write the book for
them to not write the book like it has
to be that much of a kind of compulsion
I don't think it's ever easier to make a
movie than not make a movie I guess
maybe just sort of from a personal right
pain pleasure standpoint like I remember
reading an anecdote now again who knows
it's the Internet but about you I
actually think this might've been from
the New Yorker about a diary entry where
you were talking about a raven Thailand
and you were like the Sun came up and
the people were dancing and the Sun came
down and the people were dancing and the
tides went out and I was miserable
because I wasn't making movies yeah
that's true that means you have to make
movies right I mean it's yeah I guess so
I mean it
I think for me it was storytelling more
than films although I think there would
definitely things in my past and
experience that you know helped me like
very early on I got into photography
into black and white photography when I
was in junior high school and I would
you know go into the darkroom and
develop the film I loved it and I don't
know why that fell into my lap it just
so happened they had this lab nearby and
I was able to take a class there and
then I just started thinking about
photographs and taking pictures and all
that so and that all led to this but I
think it could have gone anyway I it's
funny because when I was in college I
didn't know what I wanted to do the
first couple of years I was in college I
hadn't discovered filmmaking till I was
a junior in college and and I remember
walking around hitting myself in the
head going I'm never gonna find what I
want and they were gonna find my calling
you know and then it happens for you
hopefully and it happened for me I found
something that I was the first time I
ever got a in college was filmmaking no
I was a b-minus student until film came
along and suddenly boom it was like
something that kept me out of my
girlfriends room you know I was like I
rather be rather be cutting the movie
than laying in bed so I was like you
know I found it but I think eventually
it comes and but it could have been a
lot of things I think I don't think
necessarily like I mean it's this weird
kind of weird art form and it could have
probably come to me in lots of different
ways it was just something that I was
like okay I see a path I see something
there and it's interesting and
fascinating and there's a lot to learn
in there and so I just went for it if I
were to ask say some of your closest
friends what your superpower is maybe
you wouldn't talk about it cuz you seem
to be a pretty understated humble guy
but what your superpower is or what
makes you different what would they say
or what might they say well I mean my
friend then is like who's doing it does
visual effects for me it was I met him
first day of freshman year at college
says you know when people ask me if I
changed I say you know what he was an
[ __ ] on college and he's still an
[ __ ]
but
exactly exactly I don't know it's hard
it's hard for me to say but definitely
one of the best things about my life as
as I talked about there is I still hang
out with the guys I went to nursery
school I still hang out with the guys I
went to high school with I still hang
out with the guys I went to college with
and I think that that having the roots
like I'm into roots um into loyalty and
I think that's prot
pretty much and I think I don't know I
had a my friend Jed once said the the
guy who dies with the most friends wins
I thought that was pretty good advice if
I were to pester your friends a little
bit more give them a few drinks
yeah and they get past the obligatory
he's still an [ __ ] if they're if they
got to like the the the the point of
drunk reminiscing yeah and sort of a the
emotional point of drunkenness yeah what
would they tribute your success to a lot
of a lot of anymore people don't make it
then make it no in the film business
whoo it's a good question
oh do you tribute we can make it direct
to I mean it's a combination I mean I
had I had excellent parents but you know
almost always supported me and always
told me that not to work so hard not to
work too hard you know when I would say
I got to go work they say well don't
work too hard was there saying I I mean
that was after I got out of college so
up to college I put they were both
schoolteachers and academics was super
important but they also created a lot of
they created very good responsibilities
and boundaries but also didn't
necessarily create opportunities but
gave me breathing room with support to
find opportunities so I struggled in my
20s but I was able to struggle in my 20s
and so that that was that was I think a
big part was having that type of support
system and my sister so family was a
major part of it
and I think that allowed me to have
persistence you know which I always say
is nine-tenths of the game is
persistence is you know you gotta get up
to the plate you know to get that chance
to take that swing and to get to the
plate just takes a lot of work but then
and then when you get there it's
preparation and homework having done all
your homework and as well as you can as
much as you can and then and then as
you're taking the swing is make it a
responsible swing for the team you know
make sure that that I love the baseball
metaphor I wonder how much longer I keep
going with your students you teach what
is the name of the class I don't see I
mean I don't do it regularly because I
haven't found the best place I taught I
want NYU for a bit and a few other
places but I mean I just I just to be
honest I kind of wing it to see what
kids are doing you know I'll come in
I'll talk to them about what their
dreams are what their projects are I'll
ask they all sort of share so I have
them all describe each other stuff but I
love doing scene study with kids where I
have them put up a scene and bring work
with actors put up a scene now this is a
this is a scene that has already
appeared no no no scene from their
projects they describe it to me they
tell me what they want I'll open up the
scene and then I'll teach him I'll give
him my my direction on how I would block
it I'll work with the actors I'll just
show them my process and then I'll take
a chalkboard out and I'll show them
let's have how how do we shoot it and
I'll just draw my designs to show them
how to draw it so I command the
chalkboard is sort of bird's-eye view
always bird eyes video that's how I've
always I came up I mean I I know the
filmmakers do it but it was when I was
20 years old starting to do films that's
how I started I always and it's probably
from playing Dungeons & Dragons as a kid
is like you know you got that sky view
and like i drew little triangles and i
came up with all these different shapes
and forms i have my own like language
that i've developed over the years for
how to do it and i have the ability to
look at that architectural plans and
then to see it in 3d below so i can
that's
I do it I do it very much from a burn I
view Dungeons and Dragons will be for
round two I was always a chaotic good
cleric Ralph
yeah you're a cleric no no I I don't
remember that well actually I mean we
played forever yeah but I don't actually
my character I'll bring some graph paper
next time if you were to this is really
do the class let's just say you could no
longer make films all right and you're
sort of divinely assigned mission was to
coach five five to ten filmmakers yeah
and not only would you get the psychic
reward of seeing them do well but much
like say someone who bankrolls a poker
player you would get a percentage of the
future what are the things you would
focus on if you had say a six month
period well I mean if I was doing that
and I had a share of it yeah
I mean that as soon as you bring the
share into it it's like all right so we
get we could we could we could approach
us a couple different so one is you get
the profit share it's it's like a 50/50
split with them plus you have a kicker
but you have to add some money all right
we could do that I would never do that
this home investments an awful invest
this is of course that's what we have
huge Chinese companies but the the other
could be really whatever reward you
would want to get out of it so it could
be the acclaim and receiving awards and
prizes and so on it could be anything
else I mean really I mean the the real I
guess the I mean the gift of any
teachers to see whatever the goals of
the student are as long as they're
righteous goals be achieved you know so
you know I would probably want to teach
students that were you know probably had
just wanted to tell good stories and
then I would want them to see them make
them as well as they could and then have
them connect with as many people as they
could the awards the money that's all
silly stuff I mean it's great for
everything but it's really has as many
issues with it as good things so I mean
it's it's just
you want to find people and I'd want to
find students that really just want to
tell stories and entertain and they'd
not that they want to be a filmmaker
because we're the rock star of the
present day or the NBA basketball player
of the day you know where it's because
that's what they want to do like when I
started telling stories it wasn't like
when I was a kid no one knew what
Spielberg did we heard the name Lucas
and Spielberg but that was it you know
but not really you know no one how do
you become a director and when I start
to do it even in the early 90s it wasn't
really it was early Sundance days wasn't
really this track record of how to do it
so I wasn't like looking for the reason
to be you know that it could lead to
something that was clear it was just
something that was interesting and
fascinating to me so at this point when
there are all these paths to you know
fame and money and all that and you know
if you make one film you can go and do a
Marvel movie or something like that
which is happening all the time now I
think you want to find people that are
looking to tell the stories and then
help them tell stories and like when I
look the last class I taught my you my
best student was a Turkish kid who was
going back to Turkey to tell a small
story about an apple tree on the on the
side of Mount Ararat that starts a
village fight and tiny story it could be
huge who knows but he was serious and he
just wanted to tell that story and so I
gravitated to him and I spent most of my
time in the class working with him to
help him because he was the guy who was
gonna go make a movie and was serious
and knew what he was doing and I said
let me focus on this kid so the other
kids can see be inspired by his path any
top scripts if somebody has never read a
screenplay or like a look just start
start with ABC I mean the guy's working
today Eric Roth Scott silver read any of
their scripts that great writers Chris
Terrio I mean there's a lot of great
writers working right now I mean this oh
it did there's a lot of good um great
scripts that I've read I mean Charlie
Kaufman's scripts are great and fun to
read it's enough
start with yeah I think so where can
people find the film where should they
learn more about it I've never had
something mamas
yes exactly oh and I bet just for
everybody listening I highly recommend
you check it out like like Darren said
like no you're signing up for a roller
coaster
yeah and but I've had nothing produce
this really unique
I'll get yelled at for modifying unique
by someone I know but that's okay I mean
just for him very unique dreamlike state
for about 18 hours afterwards it was
amazing yeah it was really profound but
where can people learn more about it
well I mean its mother with a lowercase
I'm at an exclamation point which causes
all different type of difficulties with
social media because of the exclamation
point but I mean by the time this comes
out I hope it's going to be around if
not you know the I mean just Google
mother movie and you'll you'll be seeing
too much about it about I hope we're
king people if they want to check you
out on social media or everything else
my full name darren aronofsky ad on
instagram and twitter yeah that's I I
you know Instagram is pretty cool i've
been doing this cool thing i don't know
if you've been following it but i I
found two young film students and they
were moving out to go to film school in
LA and I rented them a big projector and
a cube truck and they've been driving
through the country projecting the word
mother in different languages onto all
different types of structures around the
country and so I've been posting these
images that these young filmmakers have
been making to help sell promote my film
but also it's it's been a fun project to
learn about all these different places
all over America it's kind of humans of
New York is that humans oh sure is that
the name of the engineer humans of New
York but more projections of mother very
cool so people can say hi to you on the
interwebs and check it out any last asks
or recommendations of the people
listening besides seeing the movie I
mean just
but keep seeing the weird stuff go out
and you know let you know support when
you and then spread the word you know so
I think you know if you dig the movie
get it out there and get everyone to go
see it I'm hoping that its type of film
that you'll want to talk to other people
about well I will I can attest certainly
with two people I saw we talked about
four hours afterwards so one of the
things I really enjoyed is the head that
does not follow the typical template any
typical template that I can that I can
see so it leads to a lot of conversation
dare to be different
dare to be different yeah well Darrin I
really appreciate the time thank you the
same it's an amazing yeah there's been
really fun and we can we can keep going
but I want to let you get back to X film
yeah polishing up everything else and to
everybody listening you can find links
to everything we've discussed including
the movie the books and so on in show
notes Tim that blog forward slash
podcast as per usual and every other
episode and until next time thank you
for listening bye bye hey guys this is
Tim again just a few more things before
you take off number one this is five
bullet Friday do you want to get a short
email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday the vet provides a little morsel
of fun before the weekend and five
bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
audible which I have used for many many
years I absolutely love audiobooks and
they are one of my favorite
is to pass the time when I travel I'm on
the road all the time and audible allows
me to consume many more books than I
possibly could otherwise I have two
audio books to recommend right off the
bat the first is perhaps my favorite
audio book of all time and it's the only
audio book I've wanted to listen to
twice in a row the graveyard book by
Neil Gaiman it's amazing and you will
thank me there are a few different
versions
I like the version that Neil narrates
himself one of the most soothing voices
of all time the second book is
vagabonding by Ralph Watts Pio tts which
had a huge impact on my life and formed
the basis for a lot of what would later
become the 4-hour workweek so go to
audible.com for word slash Tim and you
can choose one of these two books or any
of many many other options that could be
books magazines and much more as a
listener of the Tim Ferriss show you can
also access a free 30-day trial just go
to audible.com forward slash Tim you
can't make more time but you can make
the most of it so turn your travel or
your commute into something more with a
free trial at audible.com forward slash
Tim to start now and get your free
30-day trial this episode is brought to
you by WordPress my go-to platform for
blogging writing online creating
websites everything I love WordPress to
bits my site every site just about that
I have is run on WordPress and the lead
developer of WordPress Matt Mullenweg
has appeared on this podcast many times
the very first episode in particular is
amazing the second I took a ton of notes
on so you should check it out but
WordPress where do I even begin I mean
the New Yorker uses it jay-z Beyonce
they use it 5:38 TechCrunch Ted CNN time
whether you are looking to create a
personal blog a business site both
neither something else you'll make a
huge impact when you build your website
on wordpress.com and directly from some
friends at Google I'm not going to quote
them by name but they say that WordPress
offers the best out-of-the-box SEO the
search engine optimization imaginable so
if you're on WordPress you immediately
have a leg up on everybody else on
search engines and so forth in my
experience I'm no medical doctor of
search engine optimization but I will
say that I used WordPress for years and
fell in love with it to the extent that
I became very close friends with Matt
and then became an investor slash
advisor to automatic which runs
WordPress com that is how much I believe
in this and that's how a lot of my most
successful products and investments have
come about because I'm in love with X
and then I seek out X nearly 30% of the
Internet is run on WordPress and that
includes everything from the huge sites
that I mentioned to neighborhood sites
and it is super easy to get started
there's no need to worry about security
or upgrades or hosting they offer 24/7
support and handle all of that which
allows you to focus on creating the
highest quality content you can with the
least amount of friction I don't have to
worry about downtime I don't have to
worry about getting emergency emails if
I'm on vacation or something like that
and WordPress is my go-to solution for
all of this I trust all of my most
important text on the internet to
WordPress and they can't buy that with a
sponsorship they can't buy that with
anything I want uptime uptime uptime and
quality and that is what I have selected
after everything that I've looked at so
check it out go to WordPress that's wor
DP re SS com wordpress.com for slash Tim
to receive 15% off of your website today
that's wordpress.com forward slash temp
[Applause]